Le terme téléportation quantique peut sembler tout droit sorti de la science-fiction, mais comme on va en parler dans l'épisode d'aujourd'hui
de Qiskit in the Classroom, c'est une technique très réelle et très utile pour la communication et
les réseaux quantiques. Bienvenue dans Qiskit in the Classroom. Dans cette série, on va utiliser Qiskit pour explorer quelques concepts fondamentaux
souvent abordés dans les cours liés à l'informatique quantique. Chaque vidéo est accompagnée d'un module interactif
lié dans la description ci-dessous, alors n'hésite pas à le consulter. La téléportation est une sorte de trope de la science-fiction et du fantastique
à ce stade. Une personne ou un objet disparaît d'un endroit et réapparaît instantanément ailleurs.
Aussi cool que ce serait, malheureusement, ce genre de téléportation du moins est impossible. Ça briserait la limite cosmique
de vitesse. Rien ne peut voyager plus vite que la lumière. Mais la téléportation quantique est
possible. Dans la téléportation quantique, l'information plutôt que la matière peut être transmise entre deux
emplacements distants. Tout ce dont tu as besoin, c'est d'une paire de particules intriquées, une à chaque site, et d'un moyen de communiquer des informations classiques
entre les deux sites. Ce protocole a été développé en 1993 par une équipe
de scientifiques quantiques, dont Charles Bennett d'IBM. Ils l'ont appelé téléportation quantique parce que, semblable à la version
science-fiction, l'information quantique disparaissait d'un endroit et apparaissait dans un autre endroit distant
sans jamais traverser l'espace intermédiaire. Ça peut sembler magique, mais comme on va le voir, il n'y a rien
de mystérieux ni de magique là-dedans. C'est permis par le phénomène de l'intrication quantique ainsi que par la
communication classique. Aujourd'hui on va parcourir le protocole de téléportation quantique et comment il fonctionne. Puis on va le mettre en
action sur un vrai ordinateur quantique pour téléporter l'état d'un qubit d'un côté d'un processeur quantique IBM vers
l'autre. Alors voici comment fonctionne une téléportation quantique. Supposons qu'on a deux personnes Alice et Bob qui sont séparées
par une grande distance. Disons qu'Alice a un qubit. On va appeler ce qubit Q juste par commodité. Et il est dans un
état quantique inconnu sq où alpha 0 et alpha 1 sont des nombres
complexes. Alice veut envoyer son état à Bob, mais elle n'a aucun moyen d'envoyer le qubit lui-même. Il se peut que
Bob soit trop loin, ou peut-être qu'elle ne sait même pas exactement où il est, donc elle ne sait pas où l'envoyer. Heureusement,
les amis partagent déjà une paire de qubits intriqués A et B, où Alice a le qubit A et Bob a le qubit B. Et
ces qubits sont intriqués. Par intriqués, je veux dire que même si les deux qubits sont séparés par une grande
distance, leurs états sont corrélés d'une manière que la physique classique ne peut pas expliquer. Cette paire intriquée est
ce qu'on appelle un Ebit, qu'on peut utiliser comme ressource en informatique et communication quantiques.
Dans ce cas, Alice peut utiliser l'EBIT comme ressource pour transmettre son information quantique à Bob. Pour voir comment, commençons
par écrire l'état conjoint de ces trois qubits où j'ai ordonné les qubits un peu arbitrairement
à ce stade, mais cet ordre sera pratique quand on lancera notre expérience sur Qiskit. Dans Qiskit, la façon standard d'
ordonner les qubits est de droite à gauche. Donc, l'état du qubit zéro apparaîtra à droite.
Développons un peu l'état et réécrivons-le comme ça. Alors la première étape de notre protocole de téléportation est
qu'Alice intrigue son qubit de données avec sa moitié du qubit EBIT en utilisant un gate C-NOT. Un gate C-NOT ou contrôlé-NOT
va changer l'état d'un qubit, le qubit cible, selon l'état d'un autre qubit, le qubit de contrôle.
Si le qubit de contrôle est dans l'état zéro, alors rien ne se passe sur la cible. Et si le qubit de contrôle est dans
l'état un, alors le qubit cible est retourné. Donc dans ce cas, le qubit de données Q d'Alice sera le qubit de contrôle et
son qubit Ebit A sera le qubit cible. Donc les deux premiers termes n'ont pas du tout changé avec le C-NOT, mais les
deux derniers termes si, parce que le qubit de contrôle Q était dans l'état un. Ensuite Alice
appliquerait un gate Hadamard à son qubit de données Q qui prend l'état 0 vers l'état 1/2 0 + 1 et l'état 1 vers
1 sur 2 0 -1. Je vais sauter quelques étapes d'algèbre simples que tu peux essayer de remplir toi-même si tu veux.
Mais après avoir réarrangé quelques termes tu obtiendras un état qui ressemble à ça. Donc maintenant l'état intriqué
à trois qubits d'Alice et Bob ressemble à un vrai gâchis. Mais regarde ce qui se passe si Alice mesure ses deux qubits. L'état à trois
qubits va partiellement s'effondrer vers l'un de ces quatre
termes. Et dans chaque cas, Bob se retrouvera avec un état de superposition dont les amplitudes sont liées à l'état
initial inconnu d'Alice. Rappelle-toi que les amplitudes sont alpha 0 et alpha 1. Donc
par exemple, si Alice mesure les deux qubits à zéro, alors l'état de Bob s'effondrera vers ce terme, l'état
inconnu original qu'Alice voulait téléporter. Mais si Alice mesure zéro sur le qubit A et un sur le qubit Q, alors l'état de Bob
sera celui-là. Cet état peut être transformé en l'état original du qubit Q si Bob
applique un gate Z, ce qui retournera ce signe ici. Mais Bob ne saura pas faire ça
tant qu'il n'aura pas appris ce qu'Alice a mesuré. Donc la prochaine étape du protocole est qu'Alice appelle Bob et lui dit ce que
ses deux mesures ont donné. Une fois qu'il le sait, il saura quelles opérations effectuer sur son qubit pour le faire correspondre
à l'état original d'Alice. Voici un tableau des quatre mesures possibles et des quatre opérations que Bob
devra effectuer sur son qubit selon ces mesures. Bob devra peut-être effectuer un gate Z, un gate X, ou les deux pour
transformer son qubit pour qu'il corresponde au qubit original d'Alice. Cette dernière étape, où Alice appelle Bob, d'ailleurs, c'est pourquoi
la téléportation quantique ne viole pas la causalité. Même si l'état de Bob s'est instantanément effondré quand Alice a mesuré
ses qubits, Bob ne pouvait tirer aucune information de cet état avant qu'Alice lui dise ce qu'elle avait mesuré. Et
cet appel était limité par la vitesse de la lumière. On vient de passer par beaucoup de maths détaillées, alors le fait incroyable
qu'on vient de téléporter de l'information quantique a peut-être été perdu de vue. Mais c'est vraiment assez incroyable. En utilisant
l'intrication comme ressource, Alice a pu faire une mesure pour détruire l'information quantique stockée chez elle et la faire
apparaître dans un autre endroit distant avec Bob. Cette distance pourrait être de centaines, voire de milliers de kilomètres. Plus
étonnant encore, ce protocole ne nécessite même pas qu'Alice sache exactement où est Bob. Tant qu'ils partagent un Ebit
et qu'ils peuvent communiquer classiquement entre eux, la téléportation quantique fonctionnera. Maintenant, voyons comment ça marche
avec Qiskit et téléporte vraiment un état quantique sur un ordinateur quantique.
On va commencer avec trois qubits, un pour le qubit de données Q et les qubits A et B qui constitueront l'E bit. On
commence par créer l'E bit. On applique un Hadamard sur le qubit A suivi d'un C-NOT
entre A et B pour créer l'état intriqué qu'on cherche.
Ensuite on prépare le qubit Q d'Alice dans un état quantique aléatoire en appliquant une unitaire aléatoire représentée par cette boîte étiquetée
U. Vient ensuite la téléportation. D'abord le C-NOT entre les qubits Q et A. Puis le Hadamard sur
le qubit Q. Ensuite les mesures font partiellement s'effondrer l'état de sorte que seul le qubit B de Bob est dans une superposition.
C'est à ce moment qu'Alice appellerait Bob pour lui dire ce qu'elle a mesuré. Ensuite Bob appliquerait certains
gates selon ces mesures. Ces boîtes à contour rouge signifient des gates conditionnels. Le premier signifie
que Bob applique un gate X à son qubit si le qubit A est mesuré à un. Et
le second signifie qu'il appliquera un gate Z également si le qubit Q est mesuré à un.
Donc maintenant Bob devrait avoir un qubit dans le même état que celui du qubit d'Alice était à ce point ici après le gate unitaire.
Si tout s'est passé comme prévu, alors on a téléporté l'état quantique. Mais comment le vérifier ? On peut faire tourner le
même circuit mais avec un petit changement.
Ici on a ajouté une autre unitaire tout à la fin du circuit appliquée au qubit de Bob. Cette unitaire est l'inverse de
celle qu'on a appliquée au début sur le qubit d'Alice. Le raisonnement ici est que si ce premier gate a créé l'
état quantique qui est maintenant téléporté vers le qubit de Bob, alors celui-ci devrait le défaire, ramenant le qubit de Bob vers l'état zéro.
Mais bien sûr, ça annule tout notre travail de téléportation de l'état en premier lieu. Donc on ne voudrait pas
faire ça si on voulait vraiment faire quelque chose avec l'état téléporté et si l'état était vraiment dans un état quantique inconnu
on ne pourrait pas appliquer une unitaire pour le défaire. Anyway, c'est purement à des fins de diagnostic pour
s'assurer que la téléportation a réussi. Si on mesure le qubit de Bob dans l'état zéro, alors on peut être raisonnablement
sûr que la téléportation a fonctionné. Une fois qu'on est sûr que notre protocole fonctionne comme prévu, on pourrait enlever cette
unitaire finale et faire vraiment quelque chose avec l'état téléporté. Mais pour l'instant, vérifions juste que ça marche. Allons
exécuter le circuit sur un ordinateur quantique. On peut utiliser le sampler primitif de Qiskit pour faire tourner ce circuit
plusieurs fois et recueillir des statistiques sur les résultats de mesure. Si on a téléporté parfaitement l'état d'Alice vers Bob à chaque fois,
alors Bob mesurerait son qubit à zéro à chaque fois, mais avec le bruit environnemental et les imperfections dans
les gates, on peut s'attendre à voir quelques exécutions où le qubit de Bob finit à un. Mais tant que la majorité du
temps le qubit de Bob est mesuré à zéro, on peut appeler ça un succès. Voici un histogramme des résultats de mesure de
tous les trois qubits. La mesure de Bob est montrée dans le premier emplacement de chaque chaîne de trois bits. Comme prévu, les quatre
résultats qui correspondent à son bit étant zéro sont bien plus probables que les quatre autres. Donc, on a réussi à
téléporter un état quantique. Mais regarde jusqu'où on a téléporté. Voici une carte de tous les
qubits du processeur quantique qu'on a utilisé. Et dans l'expérience, on n'a utilisé que ces trois qubits.
Le qubit d'Alice était ici et celui de Bob était là. Donc ils étaient presque côte à côte. On aurait pu
obtenir la même chose en appliquant juste quelques gates swap, qui, comme le nom le suggère, échangent simplement les états quantiques
de deux qubits voisins. La téléportation quantique est utile pour transporter l'information quantique sur de longues distances, et
des états quantiques ont déjà été téléportés sur des centaines de kilomètres. Pour nos expériences ici, on est limités par la
taille de la puce, mais on pourrait rendre la téléportation un peu plus impressionnante en téléportant un état entre deux
qubits distants sur notre ordinateur quantique. Alors, essayons ça. Voici notre nouveau schéma de circuit. Il a l'air un peu plus
compliqué, mais rien n'a fondamentalement changé sauf que maintenant Alice et Bob créent leur EBIT partagé,
puis se séparent. Cette série de lignes et de X représente des gates swap qui déplacent
les états d'Alice et Bob d'un qubit à un autre. Alice monte vers le qubit 1 et
Bob descend vers le qubit 12. Ensuite Alice crée son état aléatoire sur le qubit 0 avec
cette unitaire. Garde à l'esprit qu'elle crée l'état après qu'elle et Bob se sont déjà
séparés. Donc Bob est déjà loin d'elle.
Puis le protocole de téléportation continue comme avant et Bob se retrouve avec l'état original d'Alice après ses
opérations conditionnelles. On applique le gate unitaire inverse et vérifions que le qubit de Bob est
dans l'état zéro. Et encore on voit que la majorité du temps le qubit de Bob a été trouvé dans l'état zéro.
La téléportation a donc réussi.
Le taux de succès n'est pas tout à fait aussi élevé que quand Alice et Bob étaient côte à côte, cependant. Tous ces gates swap
peuvent être coûteux et faire se dégrader l'EBIT un peu. La téléportation quantique peut sembler magique, mais comme on a
vu, tout ce qu'il faut c'est de l'intrication, un canal de communication classique, et un peu d'ingéniosité. La proposition originale de 1993
qu'on a couverte dans cette vidéo a posé les bases d'autres protocoles comme la téléportation de gate quantique
et est un ingrédient essentiel pour le calcul et les communications quantiques.
Sur le front expérimental, les scientifiques ont continué à repousser les limites de la téléportation quantique, réussissant même à téléporter
l'état quantique d'un photon entre un laboratoire sur Terre et un satellite à 1 400 km
au-dessus. Et à téléporter des états quantiques à travers un câble Internet classique bruyant. Si tu veux téléporter ton propre
état quantique, rends-toi sur le module de téléportation quantique lié dans la description ci-dessous. Merci d'avoir regardé
et à la prochaine.